now setting up home in America the
Sussex is have set their boundaries with
the tabloids back in the UK telling the
Sun the mail the Express and the mirror
they will no longer have anything to do
with them this policy they say is not
about avoiding criticism it's not about
shutting down public conversation or
censoring accurate reporting medium have
every right to report on and indeed have
an opinion on the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex good or bad but it can't be based
on a lie a bold move from a couple
who've had enough of being clickbait
repeats is inaccurate inclusive an
abusive stories about their personal
lives for several years now and the
context of this of course is that
newspapers are one of the few industries
in the UK which aren't properly
regulated so they can say almost
anything they like about these people
with impunity so in a sense it's no
surprise that they've taken a stand and
finally said that they've in the middle
of a global pandemic the timing of the
letter may seem ill-advised Harry and
Megan have been working with charities
helping those affected by cope at 19 for
their latest announcement has
overshadowed a rare statement from
Prince Phillip praising key workers and
Prince Charles opening a temporary
hospital in Wales it's an absolute own
goal because now those papers they said
they won't cooperate with have it just
be a habit
they'll print anything now they have
done the right thing because they are
protecting their privacy and also
they're protecting the privacy of the
kid or chief I think they should have
waited you know specifically once this
all dies down and just let the dust
settle with kovat because everyone's
going through hard times at the moment
but this is one of the reasons they've
done this now Megan's legal action
against the mail on Sunday for
publishing a letter to her father the
first high court hearing is due to take
place on Friday albeit remotely because
the restrictions around coronavirus I
understand that Harry and Megan wanted
to send that letter to tabloid editors
before the proceedings really got
underway but however
intend to deal with the media in the
future there will be huge interest in
this case and a potentially explosive
evidence that could come from both sides
a court case in which private texts
between father and daughter are already
being made public extraordinary from
members of the royal family pitting the
right of freedom expression of the media
against the personal privacy rights of
individuals and this happens in cases
frequently seen by the courts and it's
up to the court to assess that balance
and to say in any given case whether the
media has overstepped its bounds the
couple may have relocated to start their
new life their ongoing battle against
the press has only moved with them with
neither side showing any sign of backing
down Rhiannon Mills Sky News in central
London